y lock my cat
in y lock the cat in bro
go what's up everybody it's your boy
Travis Hunter and we back with another
stream or podcast or whatever you want
to call it but welcome back to 12 talks
let's get right into it off overlooking
the stadium I want to wake up and see
the stadium I want to wake up and feel
it I want to see it empty see the
transformation is pretty much what we're
doing yeah that's just coach Prime
pretty much saying he slept in his
office before the game I wish I could
did that I wanted to see this Stadium
empty then turn into full that fast but
yeah Stadium got packed fast the game
was early I was up by like 5:45 that
morning I was just ready to go I
couldn't sleep I can't never sleep on
game days I'll just be too ready too
Focus yeah had a good day
coach slept in his
office that's it I don't see the chat
waiting on the chat to load up what
Saucy
beat Bucky they looking for
you Travis you're lowkey the most
underrated player in the
NCA hey man I don't know what to tell
them dog they gonna keep sleeping on me
so I'm going just go ahead and keep
doing what I do best and that's go out
there perform how I'm supposed to to
just put six bills on me to win the
hosman come on man you gening me now you
can't bet on me let me just go out there
and do it first how you think shador
played he played good we could have
played a lot better we got still a lot
of things to work on we trying to be
perfect and that was not a not a perfect
game for us I mean we came out slow
defense helped out a lot with the
offense so yeah 100 Mil I need
it how long is your scream I think this
scam is like 4 5
minutes or it can go as long as I want
it to go pretty
much what's the TD dance this year you
gota wait and see
it oh this chat moving
moving
Godly what's my favorite movie My
favorite movie is The Blind
Side the longest
yard uh what else I
got
uh what Friday and Friday every Friday I
like all those movies thank you man I
appreciate you watching and supporting
us the onesie is swag yeah I know look
Lanna got it for me she got me a stitch
hard y'all know I love being in pajamas
always in
pajamas conat on success as young black
man I'm so proud of you keep up the work
thank you I will what is your favorite
positioner
DB I like both of them I don't have a
favorite Colorado
de custom M SC hand suits before the
Nebraska
game yeah coach prom gonna always get
the suits right I mean we had them at
Jackson State now we have a tough one I
like this suit pants a little tight but
I we're gonna adjust that yeah my suit
swaggy before pregame I wish we had a
picture of pregame I was looking swaggy
at the Travis Scott song yeah I got drip
that's first time with to trais Scots
too do the ab dance after the touchdown
all right bet put
that you know how I get what is this oh
this the bus ride yeah I was waing in
front I was oh yeah no I wasn't I was
right in front of him I was was just
listening to music doing my own thing
getting ready before the
game the bus be pretty quiet though
everybody just had their headphones on
just ready to get to the stadium get to
work ready to play at this point all the
meters and stuff is over with it's time
to go out there and just perform top
five corners in the NFL
ah oh no man the NFL season just not
started it's a lot of good Corners out
there though it's a lot of J Alexander
just just just clamping his side in the
Green Bay
game so yeah doing big things how many T
you think you gonna get this year I
don't know as many as got provide
me no this is not w w Melly
what what's
next I'm good to move on let's go to the
next thing car a turnover Thor Thorn
versus
Nebraska yeah I seen it on the Seline
but I a get to sit in it because they
ain't get no turnover so I was kind of
mad but yeah that chair is nice it's
tough I'm going to have one in my room
to sit in one for uh the
stream I was just picking on him
yesterday about this when we went to
practice said if that was me you flash
your wash in front of me bro I would
have slap your your arm so fast you
ain't F to flex on me like that I know
you got money let me have
some but yeah he did what he was
supposed to do that was on on our logo
talking mess so he went out there and
stood on business and that's what we're
about don't we ain't let nobody respect
us and we ain't going to disrespect
nobody yeah bro I'm not GNA lie I
thought he was tackled like 20 times ago
but he wasn't I'm in the back of the
endzone that's my cousin Hank who caught
the pass which they say he dropped it
but he was so turn but yeah we hey man I
don't know how he got out of that man he
just he was breaking me you know scrimer
rules you got to find open grass try to
get in his view in his vision it was
hard cuz I thought he was going the
other way he came back thought he got
tackle he pop up again he threw the ball
so I'm like God Dam bro what's going
on but yeah he tried to do what he do
best and that's get the ball in somebody
hands one of The Playmakers that's a
nice play though I like that let's play
2K R bro a going lie
bro I'm trash at 2K right now I'm
playing shot so slow bro I'mma fix it
I'm going get it right though shador top
three quarterbacks yes he's top
one
yes next what we got
next what is
this oh
yeah I thought he was going to pass to
me right here I ain't going to lie he
looked like he was I was trying to get
in his vision but he scored I was right
there cuz I thought he was passing it to
me but
yeah that's his first first running
rushing touchdown right I think so he do
what he supposed to do though got the
ball in the end zone we got to continue
to complete the drives in the Red Zone
that's our main thing we getting that
Red Zone it's time to score we're not
looking for three points we trying to
get
seven and then he did Coach Prime little
little celebration dance I was trying to
be the first to do that but I ain't
getting answer on before him so hey he
did it first I'mma do M on the pick six
so be waiting on that what do I think
about CU campus uh it's just a campus
another
school I gotta play on the basketball
team too nah man I can't play on the
basketball team coach Tom not going to
let that slide already play almost 120
snaps a game
so he definitely not gonna let that
slide I need my rest in all season can't
be out there trying to play basketball
too do we think we making the playoff
this year hey we gonna try to do our
best to get to the
playoffs that's our main goal is to go
one and 0 every week so that's where the
outcome is that's going to be the
outcome what do I think about college
game they coming to both of this
Saturday bro I wish they just got here
early in the morning so we could play
early cuz late games it's the hardest
games you literally just sit there
waiting and waiting there's nothing you
can really do got walkthroughs you got
meetings it's like a whole another day
of practice and then you got a whole
game at the end of it
so a away games is just I mean not away
games uh late games is just the hardest
games to play King shout out Jackson
shout out to Jackson
man who was my favorite NBA player it's
Kevin Durant I like Kevin Durant man I
agree watching Kevin Durant he be going
crazy can you hoop too yes I can hoop
I'm really I was really born a
basketball player but I just decided to
pursue football that's all I was
actually I'm capping football I just got
offerson basketball I
didn't so yeah
if you got offer any car with the nil
deal what car would you choose uh TRX
or a Tesla something simple I don't like
flashy cars I like trucks now so it
probably will be a truck and not a Tesla
but I might get a Tesla soon you never
know what we got
next to grade his Prime Time shuffle
after he scored that rushing touchdown
he said it's in his blood and he gave
it was horrible it was hor cuz he don't
kick the feet up he don't he he don't he
don't want
it excuse me no no he don't want it he
he he don't have shador is not a Dancer
the only Dan I can't dance either the
only dancer in our family is is uh bossy
my daughter she's the only one that
really has Rhythm the rest of us we
didn't get that the Lord passed us when
it came to dancing coach I asked Shor to
grade his prime definely Can't Dance and
yeah that Prime Time shuffle was trash
but we gonna let it slide he tried he
did good he did his he did his best I'm
G show you how to really do it when I
bring it out it's gonna be over with
everybody gon
like Marvel or DC I don't know I don't
watch that
stuff look got this oh oh my God
ankles where you going I was trying to
get loose I ain't going to lie trying to
get up out of there I don't like being T
that's why I be trying to uh get loose
trying to find my nearest uh the nearest
out of bounds or the the fastest way to
get to get to the touchdown that's why I
don't like getting touched but yeah I
broke him I didn't even know it looked
that bad until uh Xavier told me number
10 on the team call him Z but I Ain know
until he told me I was like it look that
b he said yeah look like you almost to
his ACA I'm like
oh but yeah I
I got loose had to
get reavers or prom of course
prom yall like that D I see
jets I see jets see
bills oh crap Stefan Diggs is him
bills Bron Jordan uh Bron I ain't Mar
Jordan
young sa a 10 man I like both of them
man you can they both good DBS bills I
have James Cook on my face hey I forgot
the bills got James Cook oh wait that
might be
tough bills dude go crazy they D got a
crazy
lineup what's my 40 time bro I'm slow I
ain't even going to lie I look fast but
I'm
slow I don't know my 40 time I just know
I'm slow but I know to get
open tell us more about your fishing uh
I grew up fishing I think me and my
cousin was like ah I probably say 10 nah
yeah 10 we just used to fish every day
we used to walk to every pun that we can
find any bottle of water that we see we
gonna fish it that's all we used to like
to do just fish so that's really the
backstory of it that's why I like
fishing so bad we used to we used to
fish every P we can see we had like what
two poles we used to ride a bike and a
scooter we used to go to Every P we find
we'll trade sometimes I ride a bike
sometimes he'll ride the bike sometimes
I'll ride a scooter sometimes he'll ride
the scooter sometimes we'll just walk
and then yeah it just love fishing
that's all we used to do growing up
fishing
football and nobody could beat my family
in football my family was crazy tough we
was all fast just going crazy we used
Play Everybody where I he be got a BBL
from he told me Dr to Miami I ain't GNA
lie but yeah that's really the back
story of fishing I just always fishing
with my cousin we always walked
everywhere and just fish so yeah what we
got
next me doing my Dancy
dance this is pregame yeah this is
pregame my pass still up yeah it's
before the game just trying to get some
energy Get Hype before the game yeah I
don't know what dance I was doing I just
was going with the beat going with the
Rhythm
yeah what bait do you use for
fishing I use a swimbait
sometimes Wacky
[Music]
Worm uh
craws and sometimes I I was supposed to
go fishing this morning but 2K came out
had to grind had to play 2K played a
little war zone
uh yeah I'm getting back on 2K after
this actually no I'm going bowling then
I'm G get on
2K what's
next yeah the jet do got Dam me my te
[Applause]
[Music]
musicy
[Applause]
oh yeah see yeah they give her her theme
music all
right that was after the game yeah
everybody was happy we want but like I
said that game behind us time to focus
on the next opponent this season going
by fast man we are already on week three
but what we got next is
called it's not called anything actually
it's just a blond ranking of college
football jerseys and yeah I can't change
my mind I gotta stick with what I said
and it's the top 10
so let me see some
pictures it's Colorado
State that's a to
10 Colorado state number
side
next Tennessee now that's
cold number two number two Tennessee I'm
g go number two that's coold Jersey man
that's hard to beat right there that's
hard to
beat
Houston yeah that's cold too not going
to lie but it kind of like Old
Miss I'm going say number four number
four number four we got room we got room
to improve I'm g go number
four Michigan State number
nine that junk is
loud that's out ofo
State yeah we GNA go Boise State boy
State oh that orange is cold too we
going to go number six number six number
six number six number six I wear that I
don't wear that I Go
Crazy Gator no that's
cold PCH I li number
eight no I should have waited
bro yeah I knew it was gonna be some hey
number
seven dang I should have waited number
seven oh my God oh my God no way brother
number five
UCF number three
UCLA dang I should have been Houston in
front of that's number one for sure
Oregon uniforms go crazy they number one
for
sure we did every team but
Colorado come on now
come on
now B report got filters
now no bro Travis love orange uh no I
don't my
brother OSU is hard what you mean bro
that Jersey right there was not hard I
ain't even going to lie to you thoughts
on the Lions this year bro I ain't going
to lie they did drop that ball down the
field so fast on they first drive they
was
moving I don't know though they got a
long season that's only week one it's a
long season it should be good though
Colorado had a coldest jerseys now that
uniform that we had on last week now
that was cold that black and white we
looking tough in that I like that
uniform well that
collect yeah that collection that we had
not collection
uh that idea that we BR out that was
nice you excited for a night game no I'm
not excited for a night game bro I just
want all the games to be in the morning
get the game and let's
go what's next you got under your bed
those all hot chips right there that's
what I used to eat when I was in the
summer when I be down here about eight
hours a
day just going crazy playing the
game
what you think
[Music]
the y'all know what we got next it's a
blur you know what time it is man let's
get
right that's not a blur but yeah he had
uh four catches for 122 yards and two
touchdowns and the first quarter is
crazy buy could have he was on track
going
for 4
500 that's a lot of freaking yards in
the first quarter imagine he would
played like every snap after that this
would have been
crazy I should try off for kicker no sir
I know I can't kick I ain't even about
to try it ain't about to embarrass
myself favorite cereal Cinnamon Toast
Crunch that was a blur too that was on
his head but that one catches
crazy that was a great
play
yeah that boy snagged Down with No Cap
F7 or speed Flex next game I'm going F7
man starting off with the F7 if I don't
like how it is I'm g go to speed FX I'm
starting off with F7 bro next game
definitely got to
next
Blue now that's a
blur that's a blur that's a blur that's
a blur that's a blur
that's a
blur that that pass is on the Rope too
oh I didn't even see this
game
blur oh he caught that third and N they
needed that too yeah that's a blur
BL bro what I seen something crazy in
the chat we going to skip over that
hey next that's blur though definitely
on his
head
he got see that one time he got on one
hand he catch that one
hand
blue n he definitely snagged that though
yeah yeah he just went
crazy now that's not a blur but that's a
nice hle
though I seen that play imagine if he
would have stayed up or heard of that
dude too and got in the end zone that
would have been crazy he heard that boy
so
fast that's tough though d you respect
USC Caleb Williams yes I do I respect
everybody hey man it's already a lot of
hatred in this world and I'm not g to
add on to it gotta bring a great
positivity man that's me that's what I
do two and the half spread was
completely
ridiculous lock lock up the decade
outside ofama K State last
year yeah we know
yeah Keon com yeah that boy is tough
he's nice oh that's my little brother
talking about some let me come train
with you this summer I got you little
bro I got you tring all right next is
the outfit for me bro I ha on my outfit
bro stits bro I don't like my onesie bro
all right this right here is just
overreaction or not overreaction it's
basically
like is it an overreaction or not
overreaction Miami will win the ACC
that's overreaction there's a lot of
good teams in the ACC that they ain't
faced yet but they did just beat Texas
ANM which was number 22 in the AP Top 25
pull so hey they could win it but I
don't think I think that's an
overreaction they got a lot of good
teams in the ACC this year that's
performing
well
[Music]
next Mark can still playing in the leag
that's not an overreaction bro look how
he just
TR he just folded that boy
D he folded that boy he can definitely
still play bro he still got it he still
got it but he pursuing something new
something something different for itself
so and he a very nice guy too very nice
guy I mess with
Mark just truck
the folded that boy
next Texas is indeed
back uh they beat BMA they look good
doing it I don't think that's a I don't
think that's a overreaction that's not
that's not an overreaction they might be
back hey they looked good playing uh
Bama they did what they were supposed to
do they went in that9 one hey that's not
overreaction they playing good right now
so I want to see why they ain't
back
next Colorado should be in the top 10
what are we at anyways oh number 18 hey
man we got a lot to work on a lot to
work on still for us to get in that top
10 so
hey
that's we got we got a lot of work on I
don't know if to say that's a
overreaction or not a overreaction
because we still got a lot to work on we
still got to go out there and play some
good teams still gotta go out and
dominate how we're supposed to so
yeah hey you got a lot to work on still
I'm a dirty player
how I don't do nothing
dirty play by the rules man and I don't
talk smack on the field I just
play
[Music]
Texas ain't hit hey man they beat Bama
bro I don't know how I don't know what
to tell
you all right next we got hosman loading
hey man number
four Jordan
Travis there we
go Jordan Travis man he had a good game
good game he been on the on uh on the
rise been doing this thing for the last
couple weeks so yeah Jordan Travis still
at number four number three Kaya
Williams still doing his thing every
week or something new what he did so hey
still doing his thing still being great
still being the player he is and giving
everybody the same let everybody know
why he won it last year so yes number
two
shador he ain't leaving number
two hey man he we started off slow but
he still put them numbers up and got us
on the right track to pull out the game
so yeah I'm G keep sador at number two
and number one is
me I didn't allow no catches this week
only had three
catches but hey sometimes you you're not
gonna have highight highlight games with
all types of highlights but yeah I did
what I was supposed to do oh yeah sat
down my side of the field caught the
passes that was thrown to me still could
put on better numbers but hey me and the
team came out with a dub so I can't be
mad and it's not all about individual
Awards either you know I'm a team player
at the end of the day I got to do it for
my team and not just for myself and yeah
you got locked down I didn't get locked
down by nobody sorry to tell you that my
brother hey it's just other receivers
was open so guess what two
did threw the ball to the opener that he
seen first that's all that
was would you play quarterback yes if I
had to I'd be dropped
back
dot do I really like that at quarterback
I used to play quarterback in high
school I was the back of
quarterback thow a couple touchdowns
that's about
it you think Reggie Bush should get a
thousand back yes I do I don't know why
they took it in the first place come on
man he earned that hardworking he did
what he had to do on the field to earn
that so I feel like you should get it
back what was the basketball highlights
I did that over the summer man I was ay
man when I get bored it either fishing
play basketball or play the game and I
made those videos playing basketball I
did it with my cousin did it with some
of my teammates yeah we just out there
having fun man just trying to stay out
of trouble and do what we like to do
have fun and that's what it's all about
we having fun with it with it all do you
go to the c Rec yes I go to the c Rec
but I'm only going in offseason not
during season I probably pop up a couple
times in off season other than that
about it Lilo and Stitch your favorite
movie no my girlfriend nickname is Lilo
everybody call her Lilo and she love she
love Lilo and Stitch and Stitch is like
her favorite like cartoon character so
everything that Stitch that I see I try
to get it for her but she brought me
this home today so I'm wearing it what's
my 2k build I got a floor spacing
slasher and he a point guard
66 got a green light on them sometimes
when you want to be did those guys from
Nebraska talk too much and not back it
up hey I don't know I don't be pay
attention to other teams when they be
talking I just go out there and play
that don't affect me that's not gonna
change how I play they not they didn't
talk on the field though they was
playing football that's what we all here
to do is play football play the game 2K
24 good it's all right it making me mad
sometimes but it's good it's all right
who my favorite college football team
growing up it was Florida state Florida
State P5 yes sir I got
P5 who fast than Jimmy hor Dylan Edwards
they both fast bro I don't know we gotta
see them race I'm G try to get N I can't
get them the race in season we gonna get
in the race after the season we're gonna
see who faster Jimmy is fast Jimmy like
zooming fast Dylan be zooming fast too
it's PS5 over Xbox to by the way how did
the restore treatment go for you it went
good for me you see I be having my legs
every game that treatment go crazy you
see that Rick Ross clip yeah I seen that
Rick Ross talking about shador
Sanders we doing the shador
Sanders no that was funny though I
watched that though
hey looking
ahead to the upcoming game and we got
Colorado
State Us Colorado stay at home 8
o'clock uh mountain time I think 10
o'clock
east that's a late
game I normally in the bed I'm normally
going upstairs and downstairs at like
eight
so that's GNA be hard for me I'm gonna
take me a nap
during the day because I take a nap
every day at like 12 get my Z's in get
my
rest but yeah we play Colorado State at
home late night game second home game I
know it's gonna be loud I know the crowd
gonna be going
crazy but yeah it's a late night game
it's gonna be a good game
and hey man we just got to go out there
and go one and0 again that's what we got
to
do other than that we got to go out
there and win got to be focused got to
come out faster on offense defense got
to play like they did last week forcing
turnovers so we just got to go out there
and play our game don't play down to
nobody level play at our level and let's
be the best team we can
be
and that's it
man catch
y'all next Monday at the same time
5:00 hope y'all enjoyed the show I will
be here next Monday at 5 o'clock like I
just said make sure y'all here make sure
engag we might come up with something
for y'all to earn people that engaged
the most but yeah it's your boy it's
your host Travis Hunter with 12 talks so
make sure you stay tuned for next Monday
and we
out
oh